[Music]
Karlsson tonight here's a question that
nobody asks why are Democrats so angry
just days from now the Democratic Party
is likely to retake the House of
Representatives and with it meaningful
political power nearly every poll
predicts that will happen we'll see but
Democrats ought to be cheerful and
confident instead they look like this
you're supporting not see this is way
more people pour your coffee on me
realize that you are normalizing and
enabling Nazis and you can fill me the
video you just saw was shot at Florida
State University but it could have been
any college campus or anywhere else that
progressives congregate effing Nazis if
the left had a slogan right now that
would be it it's not an expression of
political ideology it's a scream of rage
it's not aimed at actual Nazis either
the group progressives are yelling at
the real enemy is America's middle class
which they consider disgusting and
immoral watch the next plane you have
racism and sexism driving this
president's voting base and we have to
call that out we have to address that we
all know make America great it doesn't
make where your white again I think
there's a bigger race racist part of
this country look we're seeing it we're
living it that's what's on Trump is
burying this election on he does have to
take some responsibility for the type of
racist bio climate that we find
ourselves in which Jake is not new this
is and you hear me say this all the time
this is in the DNA of America it's in
the DNA of America so the country that
vanquished the Nazis is itself a Nazi
country that's their position is this
something Democrats are saying in order
to get out the vote next Tuesday
probably not it's hard to see how that
would be an effective campaign tactic
they're saying it because they were
the left is so angry they can no longer
reason think back a few years ago to all
the public figures that you once
considered impressive you might not have
agreed with their politics but there was
no question they were serious people
David Gergen Bill Kristol James clapper
where are those people today well
they're foaming and ranting on Twitter
like drunk children how about John
Brennan not so long ago Brennan ran the
CIA that's a serious job here's what
John Brennan sounds like now he is
feeding and fueling hatred and animosity
and misunderstandings among Americans I
used the term that this is nothing short
of treasonous because it is a betrayal
of the nation he is giving aid and
comfort to the enemy treasonous is
defined as a betrayal of trust as well
as aiding abetting the enemy and so that
was the word that came to my mind
treason aiding and abetting the enemy
people didn't use to say things like
that in public not for a long time now
it's just another midday panel on MSNBC
meanwhile the rest of us are far less
free to say what we think that we were
just a few years ago our culture grows
less open and more stifling by the day
comedians no longer tell unapproved
jokes scientists must abandon
politically unpopular research ordinary
people live in fear that a snitch from
the sensitivity department down the hall
will catch them in even the smallest
violation of the liberal catechism and
they'll be fired and humiliated the left
is clamping down with maximum force on
dissent they demand nothing less than
total obedience to their ever-expanding
programs whose outlines change and are
confusing step out of line though and
they will hurt you so why is the left
doing this well because they're losing
and they know it take a step back for a
minute is humorless political
correctness the hallmark of
self-confidence no it's just the
opposite victorious armies don't behave
like this crumbling regimes do this is
how you act when you feel your power
slipping away
Democrats will likely win the election
on Tuesday they may win the next
election - ultimately it doesn't really
matter because their program is over
it doesn't work voters are rejecting
their ideas and they're doing it around
the world in country after country
globalism and cultural liberalism are
dying if you watch CNN you might
conclude that America is somehow an
international pariah for having a
president who calls himself a
nationalist but if anything Trump is
just one among many how many major
democracies still have governments even
close to as liberal as the American
Democratic Party almost none of them
it's all moving in the opposite
direction and it's moving at high speed
voters everywhere want their leaders to
care about and protect them the global
is left can never deliver on that
because they cannot acknowledge that the
concerns of one country might outweigh
those of any other country it would be
as if your parents love the neighbors
kids as much as they loved you maybe
more you would hate that voters hate
that that's why as long as democracy is
allowed the globalist left is doomed
progressives know that they can smell it
and it terrifies them so they crack down
on the population in the end that will
not work you can't bully and harangue
your own people forever there is a limit
and we are reaching that limit keep this
in mind as you watch the election
returns on Tuesday night what we're
seeing is not the ascendance of the
modern Democratic platform but its death
throes